the crowds are coming back to the
henderson water street district the
latest area in the valley seeing an
increase of people getting out of their
homes going to have some fun
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
visited the area to see what's happening
as people get vaccinated they're
starting to feel safe and wanting to
visit the water street district again
a lot more cars on the street and busier
a bustle of activity
even on a thursday afternoon we feel
after both of us being vaccinated that
it's time to go out and kind of refuel
the economy
scott altman and his wife eat lunch at
juan's flaming fajitas and cantina
a restaurant welcoming guests who want
to get out of the house
the foot traffic has started to pick up
owner juan vazquez tells me it's coming
close to pre-pandemic days
how has business been for you knock on
wood we're definitely blessed and
business has been good for us you know
all things considering
hitting the business jackpot recently
even with capacity restrictions
emerald island casino our first quarter
was the best quarter in our 18-year
history
exceeding co-owner tim brooks
expectations about people returning to
the area we knew that there was pinup
demand
however we didn't expect it to be that
pin up
the city of henderson credits the
lifeguard arena opening and businesses
coming here
despite the pandemic's negative impact
it also gave downtown a chance to finish
construction projects
in some ways it allowed for us to be
positioning ourselves for this increase
in traffic
[Music]
that includes altman and others who have
a reason to visit
kristin drummond 8 news now the friday
night music series is back now right
along water street it is every friday
between
six and eight at night a great outdoor
experience and
well it's back